that died suddenly documentary people
are like there's evidence that people
are having like I don't know if it's
myocarditis they don't know what but
they're calling them they're calling
them white what the guy called he called
it white fibrous clot yeah and we don't
know what they are and my question is
for that stuff like have they have they
sent those things to a lab for sampling
to see what they're made of because it
because like what is that material like
collagen or something yeah I think I
think probably most people watching this
have seen that documentary I think it it
jumps the gun in in a couple of ways and
uh but either way it highlights
something really weird going on yeah
well you're not supposed to from what
I've learned growing up you're not
supposed to get vaccinated for diseases
you currently have it's only you get it
before the hand so that it prevents you
from getting it that's the idea or it
makes your immune system more robust if
you do but if you have the disease and
then you vaccinate that's like overdoing
many many many years ago natural
immunity is best you know but but I'm
pretty sure even the covid policy is and
and talk to your doctor about what's
right for you but I'm pretty sure it's
you can't get it if you had covet within
a certain time period like you're not
supposed to get a reasonable doctors are
saying that but the federal government
is not I'm very concerned if people had
coveted large amounts and it was messing
up their their clotting stuff and then
they get a vaccine on top of that which
might also be messing up that so that's
why I I have a question about this
though because uh you know I I've
certain I watched that documentary and
it was uh really well made I mean like
the quality like the Cinematic shots
like from symmetology perspective wow
and there's a lot of real interesting
things that came up uh because of it and
I uh I tweeted that it was a conspiracy
that all these embalmers and doctors got
together and planned to discuss this on
camera I'm kidding right certainly there
is something they're experiencing
something that's happening and I've
showed I've shown it to a bunch of my
friends I'm sure many people did but the
question I have is one we don't exactly
know what's causing this or why we just
know it's something new that embalmers
are seeing and they're not they don't
know what it is and there are some
doctors who are also like they they show
clips of people getting their their
alive there's living people getting
these clots pulled out and they're
calling them white fibrous clots my my
thought is this
you look at what's going on in China
and they're welding people's doors shut
they are absolutely terrified of covid
you look at what's going on with this
documentary died suddenly in these white
fibrous clots
the documentary Paints the picture as
though it's the vaccines I don't think
we know that I I think obviously people
are saying this this large wide scale
Global thing happened therefore you know
we assume this is the case and I'm also
like yeah but covet happened too so
here's my thoughts and again I know a
lot of people are going to get mad I'm
just let me open and I'll of course say
you know I don't know I'm not a
scientist I'm not a doctor this is this
is you get your medical advice from
people that you trust who are real
doctors but if there's if there's an
ongoing theory that kovid came from a
lab where they're doing experimentation
isn't it possible that what we're seeing
in terms of these blood clots are the
result of some kind of weaponized virus
or the gain of function research created
something so dangerous that China's
reaction is to weld doors shut in fear
of what the virus could be doing well if
you see what the Chinese government was
doing it was never really about health a
lot of this wasn't about health since of
course A lot of these Health policies
actually led to a degradation of
people's Health not only mental health
cognitive speaking skills especially
when it came to small children physical
health mental health all of that went
dramatically down and they knew it would
because there was warnings there was
people saying hey when when you when you
cause this much uh suffering for
Humanity there's going to be larger
consequences and there's even a lot of
Mainline professionals arguing that it
was the lockdowns the the health
restrictions that actually caused more
pain Havoc suffering and death than
actually the the sickness itself there's
also a doctor Asim malhorta Malhotra who
was just on Tucker cross he's a
cardiologist from the United Kingdom he
was actually in the advertisements in
the United Kingdom telling people to
take this particular product
um he had his father die he believes his
father died from that particular product
he's coming out and sharing a lot of
very crazy data and information from his
profession that is connecting some of
these dots again I'm not a medical
doctor I'm not here to give anyone any
kind of medical advice but doctor
assim Malhotra is making some really
interesting arguments right now and I
don't want to uh rehash World
conversation so I want to I want to ask
additionally another question well I I
guess it's always rehashing something so
the the thought I suppose is are they
terrified of the virus that's why
they're welding doors shut that's why
they're maintaining zero covid we know
that kovid has uh well I should say it
has been reported covet is more likely
to impact Asians because they have more
ace2 receptors so all of a sudden you
have China just going nuts my other
question is pick and choose your
conspiracy I guess yes is this the great
reset is it that China has a massive 1.3
billion human population and so
according to those who are trying to
curtail human growth and expansion and
pollution the reason China's in such
heavy lockdown is not coveted it is
carbon
they have I mean to me it's Psychopathic
totalitarian control because if you look
at the way that the Chinese government
has been operating and who have they
been working with especially when it
comes to a lot of the bigger Elites it's
always been about beta testing the
latest surveillance technology whether
it's the social credit score whether
it's punishing people for thinking the
wrong thing whether it's finding people
and taking money out of their bank
account for jaywalking the latest and
worst 1984 Vision you could imagine is
being tested right now in China and I
think this goes along with these
lockdowns which are which are continuing
this larger progression that they've
been making against free Humanity I I
definitely think you know we agree it's
dictatorship it's insane I guess my
question is the motivation behind it is
it just to experiment total control or
is there something motivating them
behind it like like uh carbon get carbon
emissions down there's too many people
in this country they want to reduce
population China doesn't give a damn
about carbon China is releasing all the
carbon in the world possibly someone
else China was being paid by the Western
the world to recycle they literally took
all the plastic dumped it in the ocean
this is why there's mild Long Islands of
plastic right now in the ocean so you
could feel better about yourself if
you're in Canada than the United States
recycling literally it's just being
dumped right into the Pacific Ocean
China is launching a lot of coal
factories China does not give a day you
don't see China setting up uh solar you
know a lot of solar facilities you don't
see them setting up wind facilities you
don't see them setting up alternative
green energies they're setting up coal
mines for a reason because they
understand how the world Works they're
they're tightening their relations with
with Russia which they're buying a lot
of gas and oil from and then reselling
it back to Europe all in the name of
green energy policies they're they're
going into Afghanistan and Mining all
the minerals there so there's no way
that they care about carbon carbon is
just an excuse for more control of
society totalitarian I would say even
satanic lockdown and destruction of the
free human Spirit but is that the
motivation then they're just like but
for lockdowns in general if you if you
looked at the original lockdowns they
locked down almost right away so I'm I'm
thinking it was originally to number one
cover up because instead of asking for
help China's a very prideful country
they don't want to ask for help from
other countries and say we have this
problem they thought they had it all
under control they could walk everyone
down and cover it up so I think maybe
that was the initial motivation behind
it but then it grew into a more hey we
can get away with this
um we have so much control over the the
people because if you think about it
from a medical standpoint too they
probably didn't know what was being
unrelished they just knew it was
dangerous or whatever and they were just
I think their initial motivation was to
try and contain it and cover it up I
disagree because if that was true they
wouldn't allow international flights if
you remember when you know covert first
hits one there was also intelligence
agencies uh talking to each other and
ramblings and documents coming out that
there was something going on of
September the year beforehand uh before
everything broke out but when China knew
so something was going on they closed
domestic travel from Wuhan you couldn't
go from muhan to Beijing you couldn't go
anywhere domestically in China from
Wuhan but you could to Italy you could
to other parts of the world that were
severely affected by this that were
depending also on slave labor Italy was
depending on a lot of Wuhan workers that
were coming in there to make made in
Italy products for for pennies on the
dollar and when you implement a policy
like that you are either sociopathic and
want this disease to spread all over the
world and you want to hurt the rest of
the world or you're just absolutely dumb
I don't think they're dumb I I think
there's a reason that they have very
high intelligence and I think this is a
part of a larger takeover and I think a
lot of this was deliberate from the very
beginning I like the conspiracy theory
that they're like the people that made
it in a lab are like oh no in two years
is when is when the second iteration of
the disease appears in people's bodies
and that's when they're really going to
change so they're freaked out change
yeah but I don't think they turn into
vampires yeah exactly when you start to
see the the big whites things come out
of their veins and they're like no lock
them all up I don't think that happened
but it's a crazy Theory no no I remember
early on in the pandemic There Was Fear
about multiple stages because uh some I
don't like I'm not a virologist or a
microbiologist or uh any other kind of
scientist or doctor so again talk to
your doctor but there was concern about
um it could come in multiple stages or
go dormant so some viruses you'll get
sick and then they go dormant and then
they can come back later
so we didn't really know what we were
seeing with this maybe uh now people are
getting weird stuff pulled out of their
veins because
because of multi-stage or something I
honestly don't know the real Vibe I get
is that the CCP is is over the top I
think totalitarian is the right word and
they just want Total Control of their
population and they want a population
reduction because they have too many men
and they're they're they're not enough
women no no absolutely not uh
what do you mean China has a population
crisis they're doing everything in their
power to try to make sure that they have
more people more women more right yeah
because of the one-time one child that
was implemented by also uh the
Rockefeller uh you know Turner Ted
Turner as well and a lot of the American
Elites came there and said you know
let's let's let's test out Eugenics here
let's see what happens when we force
people to have one child and the Chinese
government said okay just tell us what
to do and I think they're still taking
orders just like they did before that's
a real thing the one child policy I
don't know if everyone knows about that
what was it in the 80s is when this
started I have to double check just to
make sure earlier in the 80s it was
really in the 80s it's crazy and they
were just like you can have one kid and
people would have like a female baby and
they'd kill it because they weren't
allowed to have more than one kid and
they wanted a boy because the boy is the
one who carries the Legacy and they took
it even further when they started saying
if you want to leave China go to Africa
which is happening right now happening
all the time you can have more than one
child if you go to Africa colonization
exactly exactly no one talks about that
yeah China's colonizing like crazy and
people think that colonization is like
this nefarious plan among you know I
should say woke people they're like
colonization the white people came it's
like right they came because it was
getting crowded and they wanted to find
a better life and they took the risk to
do it people in China it's getting
crowded and so they're like you know I'm
gonna go move to another country and
have a family there and that is
colonization yes they're creating you
know little chinatowns which have have
uh actually if you've ever been to New
York it's awesome there's really great
restaurants but the end result is you
start seeing a shift in the culture of
of you know where they end up going
that's what colonization does
I think what we need is Mars
colonization Elon how about it I'm so
excited to colonize Mars
what we got oh you're wearing it there's
this meteor stream that we go through uh
every 1200 000 12 000 years or so it's
called the torrid meteor stream it looks
like it's coming from Taurus the
constellation so we call it the torrid
meteor strings of Taurus and uh that's
the cow those are the Comets that hit
Earth the meteors that hit Earth 12 000
years ago that ended the Ice Age melted
the you know the the flood myth wiped
out Atlantis wiped out culture well
we're in that toward meteor stream again
for the so it's 12 000 years later we're
here again we're for the next 35 years
what we need to do is redirect those
those meteors into Mars we can do that
we can nudge them start peppering the
surface of Mars with this heat and then
start melting that ice didn't we do a
test on that recently like uh slightly
changing the trajectory of like a meteor
yeah it was called the dart I think
Billy's called the DART program NASA
um and what they did I think what they
did was they hit it with an explosive
and shattered it I could be wrong
but yeah they're they are they are
avidly working on ways to move asteroids
meteors and comets
um I don't know if shattering it's the
right move because commentary fragments
can still destroy us thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time